valls ont fait un numéro je suis fort et
vous allez voir ce que je vais faire
mais il va s'écraser d'abaisser son slip
parce que non parce que la vraie raison
c'est que les français
combien de français sans travailleurs
détachés bénéficient de cette directive
troisième pays exportateur il est
troisième pays à bénéficier de cette
directive donc dans ce que l'on perd
d'un côté le problème c'est que ceux qui
perdent ce n'est pas ce qu'ils gagnent
mais globalement la france est plutôt la
gagnante dans cette directive
elle exporte ses travailleurs qui
viennent entre guillemets faire du
dumping dans d'autres pays peut-être